we're here at for your consideration
which is an exhibit that we're doing
with the Academy and for the Oscar
season and basically we have nine of our
favorite favorite artists create pieces
all based on the best picture nominees
this year this great about gallery 88
and there was a guy at the academy sort
of teamed up with them was because they
are what it's all about with pop culture
heart and to have this exhibit of all
just Best Picture nominees is really
going to bring them out and people who
haven't seen them we love artists that
can say so much it's so middle sort of
the things that we do the best with are
people who convey a pole emotion without
making it seem flutter it's like the
ultimate experience to work with the
options they found all these artists and
and I love all have seen every single
one of the movies you know a lot of them
made my top of the year really fantastic
to see something as big as the academy
awards and the oscars coming through and
recognizing that this screen printing
community and Dahlia 1988 specifically
but it comes from a passionate place
every artist that we work with as a cop
and we want to sort of be part of that
and show our kingdom and we try to make
sure that they have the same feeling
creating the poster that they do leaving
the theater once the word Oscars
government should do is big deal coup de
bras at all along in the 85th official
Academy Award poster
put each year and represented each
year's Best Picture nominee by doing
small modifications the statue to
represent the movies that you would get
it across from sort of a quick fast way
and that's the results you see the
Schiller just one is beautiful and he
can do that but yet make a really funny
one also for a beautiful mind it's just
a missing trophy like it never existed
it's an honor to be part of the shell of
everything
still kind of reeling from that feeling
I mean it made me want to see these
movies I've been sort of the best source
when I hit the heart